Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cutters. This is a short video on just how to get on and utilize our member site
So all of our information that we want our patients to know and to follow
including all our announcements changes in Zoom calls
Registration for Zoom calls your binder reviews your genetic reviews everything is on this member site
So you have to be able to access it. So hopefully this will help answer some of the questions
Especially for those that aren't quite as computer literate. When you start with us and
We you know receive your paper work back receive your payment and you're beginning care with us
We send you out the rife
First we send you out the cheek swabs and the genetic kit and such
We're probably already past that once you're watching this video
But then we send you access to the member site and in your email
It'll look something like this now. I can only do a screenshot of my email, which is Gmail
So if you have Yahoo or some other email service, it may look something different in Gmail
I have the separation of primary social promotions. Maybe your Gmail is set up even a little bit different than that
But this is what the email will come in your inbox as
Cutters clinic get your exclusive access
Cutters clinic. We're so excited to share with this and however long big your email allows you know
Whatever text to be in there, but this is what it should look like so
Once you sign up with us once you start with us and we get going with you then you'll receive this email
So start looking for that email so you can access the site. Now understand you may go into your spam or promotions or whatever your email server calls
junkmail, maybe it's in something like that. So please look in there as well and
So you're searching around you still can't find it. How do you search for an email that you're unable to find?
Well open up your email account that you're using to communicate with us
Now a little caveat make sure you're using the email some people have multiple email services
Make sure you're using the email that you are
Communicating with us with with with Angie your air. It has sent you your forms your
DocuSize your form stack signs what email that we have been sending you information with so if you have multiple email accounts
You need to look in that primary email if you're a child
Of a parent that you're helping you need to look in who's ever email account that we are doing all the communication with them
We're sending the forms to that we're sending the
Information emails to look in that email account open up the email account that you're using to communicate with us and look for that
invitation that we sent
So remember it may be in your spam it may be in your promotion or maybe in your junk bill
But if you still can't find it then type in this statement join our new patient support membership site
Type it in the search bar. You have a search bar every email
Server has a search bar so you can search for emails
You can type that in there and then you hit enter and it should come up and you should find that email
Find the search bar in your folder type it that in and hit enter and then you'll
Look for that email that join our new support member site email will show up click on that
so
That's how you'd find an email if I got lost in your junk folder you can't find it
I don't think I ever got an invitation
When we started this membership site in April everybody got an invitation so
Make sure you just search for it. So it is usually back in April so if you didn't start tell me it's it's gonna be back then
Then you'll see this you'll see Conner's clinic has given you access to
Cancer membership site. This is the email that you'll see once you click on that. So you click on that you'll see this
So pretty easy to understand you just walk through the steps from here
First you'll need to register so if you have never registered this is new you haven't been on the membership site
Click this button right here register to view content
So click that in order to register if you've already gone through the registration
Well, then you don't need to click that just click on the you've been granted access and click on that
But let's say you have it. This is new you need to create a password
So follow the instructions to create a password. It says password must be at least eight characters
Lose and include a lower an upper clay case letters a number and a symbol
So create yourself a password and then type in that same password to confirm your password and you're gonna be ready to go
Just click save password and it'll open up you into the member site and this is what you're gonna see on the home page
I just took a screenshot of the upper part of the home page
So you want to make yourself very familiar with the member site. There's a lot in there
Understand also that your password to the site is not known by us
So let's say you forget your password and you can't call us and ask us what your password is you'll have to reset your password because we don't know what your password is
So you can change it if you forgot it by clicking the forgot password just like you'd log into any site or anything else
You're doing you cannot change the email. That is your fixed user name so you can't change that
Oh, I want to receive this to my other email. You can't change that you'll need to contact us so we can change your fixed user name
That is only
Set that set by us
But in the member site
That we want you to search through and become familiar with because it gives us
Announcements so we put announcements in there so something came up just a couple weeks ago. I had to cancel a zoom call
So I put that announcement in there
Zoom makes us reset our the zoom ID number so we have to get
Registered you'll have to re register for the zoom links on a very regular basis. Now they're having us do that even more regular
It's just a way to protect everybody
So you'll see the announcements in there and you'll see a top bar that has a rife
Care instructions resources all information regarding the zoom calls in each one of these
Many of these have pull downs have dropped out so under care. It's by the reviews labs genetic reviews
So you want to become familiar with this look through this whole membership site
It's a full website and there's a lot of information in there that is very going to be very helpful to you a lot of
Information most the information is not available on a regular website. It's not available to the public
So make sure you watch the videos in there look at the information in there look at any updates in there
We update this on a very regular basis
So this isn't something that I want you to look at and then you're done looking at you'd ever look at again because any changes to anything
The way we're doing as far as patient care any changes to how we're dealing with different issues any announcements
to
Anything that's going on in the clinic is done through there
We don't send out a mass email to an announcement to
Work canceling tonight's zoom call for instance
It will be announced in the members site
So that will be just an expectation that we have of you to go to this as your first primary way to communicate with us
But one of the first things that you're going to look at when you look at this and you're new to the clinic
Because you're going to want to get on the zoom calls. So go to that
Upper right hand side green where it says zoom calls. You'll click on that
You'll open up this page that says zoom calls
You're going to want to register for the binder review zoom
You're going to want to register for the genetic review zoom we can wait on that actually
But you definitely want to register for the weekly zooms
So see that red box of the bottom it says new new zoom links
So this is new we had to re-op all our zoom links
Registration required and then once you register for the zoom call if it's a recurring zoom call
Like ends Monday zoom call at noon or my zoom call every Wednesday at four central time both of those
You'll get an email with the new with the ID not a new ID the new ID that once you register
And then you'll be able to get into the zoom call. So that's
I just we can't make it any easier there because it's just zooms requirements
There isn't video on this page too
If you're completely new to zoom calls now most people aren't especially the last couple years
But if you're completely new to zoom call you could click on that video from zoom company
And they walk you through how to use zoom that will help you a little bit
Another one of the first things you'll be looking at because you
Do want to start using your rife so when you get your rife machine you want to know how to use it
That's the whole idea right so on the rife page you're gonna have a rife setup video
rife troubleshooting guide
rife tutorial videos there's dozens and videos on this page really everything you need to know about rife
So we want you to watch those so you really feel comfortable with using the rife so as soon as you get it
Let's say it's a Saturday you can get it going and you got it running at the right away
So pretty easy to use
For those who are using it, you know that it is fairly easy to use
But if you're due to it, it's confusing
So we have all these resources on the rife resources page
Another one of the first things you're gonna do is you're gonna make sure that you get registered for the binder review
The binder review is when we go over your
specific cancer binder the three ring binder that we're sending
Now some people have skipped this because it's like okay
You can read and you don't need to go over this you read it, but I suggest you don't
So we don't want you to make mistakes by supplements that you don't need to not get things you should get
And
Make sure you register for that that's every Tuesday at 11 o'clock and again
You just click this button to register for that under the binder reviews
So everything is on this site for you to be helped. We want this site to be your go-to
This is really what our purpose is for you to be you know, feel like you're connected and you're communicated
We have two Zoom calls a week. We want you to be on and learn from other people's questions
Even if you don't have questions, but you have to follow this procedure and get registered
That's what Zoom makes us do
and
Instead of try to send out mass emails that people don't get to things
We try to just send out one email when you start with us to get on the site and all the communication is through that
Hope this helps you and hope that you're blessed by everything that we're doing
I ask that you continue to pray for us. We will be praying for you. Thanks